I mean I have a have an answer but I
don't think it'll ever happen I mean
one of the problems you have is that you
know you can a lot of compensation has
become so front-loaded that you can you
know make a thousand times what the
typical individual makes in a year and
you know basically in one year make
enough where you don't ever have to
worry about anything okay so one of the
things that would help is to say that
when you get a bonus or when you
exercise stock options that you don't
get cash what you get instead is a form
of restricted stock which basically
vests over three or five or ten years
but the problem is who's going to insist
on that certainly won't be the states in
which companies are incorporated I you
know and the last time the you know the
Congress tried to start to get in the
way of compensation they actually
created more of a mess and they solved
because they didn't want to deduct more
than a million bucks compensation unless
it was performance-based and at risk
well then people people who are able to
use that to leverage into huge
expansions of payments I think you know
it's it's it's funny to me because I
think at the same time that the private
enterprise is the source of our
prosperity but that as a result of I an
a my theory but it's it's it's you know
very vague on it I believe as a result
the loss of ethical principles which did
it here certainly did the New Deal and
were exemplified by participation things
like world war two a loss of social
spiritedness that we've come to sort of
the worst aspects of private enterprise
which you know give sort of face time to
public concern but it's it's just it's
just a
it just faces and so like so many of us
and I'm not excluding myself you know
it's definitely thinking about what John
Kennedy said I think we all effectively
ignore it everyone and in terms of
asking not what you can do for your
country and I think that one of the
worst aspects is that we people have
forgotten that it is possible to do very
well while creating real value maybe you
might do a little bit better by creating
a loser e value but you can do very well
compared to ninety-nine point nine
percent of the people who ever lived
just doing a good job and I think and
and I think that our adoration of people
who are worth a hundred million billion
10 billion whatever has created a
situation whether it's all people think
about they don't think about anything
except for that and as a result there
are no limits on what they're willing to
do and I think ultimately that's going
to thinking like that will ultimately
take this country down I don't know and
what sort of crisis we'll see but i
expect the crisis because none of us are
really thinking about how we should
conduct ourselves for the common weal